en 1959 le général de gaulle recevait le
président américain dwight eisenhower au
château de rambouillet pour un sommet
d'état un événement d'envergure
internationale que polarise production
vous propose de revivre sur place
bienvenue au château de rambouillet la
conseillère paris fille qui nous plaît
je vais vous montez dans vos
appartements
le spectacle est immersif toute l'équipe
vous met dans la peau d'un membre de
délégation dans cette pièce un centre de
renseignement sera reconstituée ici il
faut imaginer arriver dans un espace
comme celui ci avec les bandes
magnétiques les écouteurs les grands
tableaux qui permettront de raconter au
public
quelle était la situation de la france
en 1959 le début du programme nucléaire
les événements évidemment en algérie
aussi la situation berlin qui pose
problème à cette époque là le public est
vraiment amener au coeur du sommet dans
les coulisses d'un sommet d'état et de
pièce en pièce
il va suivre l'évolution de ceux de ce
sommet par ici madame la conseillère
voici la réserver aux délégations
étrangères pour que le spectacle nommé
secret défense soit réussie la
production recherche plus de 600
bénévoles car en plus d'être immersive
la reconstitution et participative ce
sont les habitants qui vont faire
revivre le lieu est l'histoire qu'il
contient en fonction de son temps libre
chacun peut trouver un rôle avec texte
pour revêtir un costume de figurants
pour des représentations qui auront lieu
en juin 2020 avec des projets comme
les projets de ce spectacle immersif
vont recréer ce lien on permet une
réappropriation des habitants du
territoire une réappropriation de ce
lieu patrimonial il se le réapproprient
et ils sont acteurs aussi de la vie de
ce lieu du développement de ce lieu
après cette présentation à la presse
l'équipe du spectacle donne rendez vous
aux volontaires prêts à embarquer dans
l'aventuré vendredi 15 novembre au
château pour une réunion d'information
et en premier casting